election in a couple days we're talking
about halloween the election yep
coming up tuesday yep now
there are over 15 propositions on the
ballot here in california
15. it's hard it's you have to look them
up to even figure out what they
are and yes you should vote for it yeah
it's crazy and even when you look them
up
and read them they're still complicated
yeah you're still not exactly sure how
to vote it's a lot to keep track of
in fact i saw an ad last night for a
proposition
i didn't even know was on the ballot
when i see tv ads for california ballot
measures
i get really confused because whether
the ads are for
or against they both use the same creepy
piano music to scare me
usually an alternating 1 5 interval on
the right hand
and a descending melodic minor
tetrachord on the left
that's why i'm voting for prop 4.5
proposition 4.5 requires advertisers to
use
major key piano music to argue in favor
of a ballot measure
and minor key progressions only for ads
urging you to vote against it
however ads in favor of a ballot measure
that warn you about the consequences of
its failure to pass can still be
in a minor key while adds against a
ballot measure that argue that its
defeat will improve the lives of
californians
would be in a major key it's just that
simple
so vote yes on prop 4.5
[Music]
or vote no